have you ever wondered where all of the
code for your favorite websites and apps
are stored maybe on some sort of network
of secret databases and servers that are
guarded by seven layers of encryption
and firewalls and more security than the
Pentagon well at one point in time that
was probably the case but nowadays
everything is on the cloud as Engineers
should be able to access the code base
from anywhere in the world at any time
hearing this you're probably inclined to
think that all of the world's code is
stored on AWS or maybe azure given the
title of the video and you wouldn't be
wrong technically it is stored on Azure
but it's no thanks to Microsoft it's
actually thanks to one of their
subsidiaries called GitHub which they
paid 72 billion for GitHub is the home
to the code repos of Airbnb Shopify
Netflix Robin Hood Reddit door Dash
Walmart and 90% of the Fortune 100 this
translates to control over 100 million
developers 4 million organizations and
330 million repositories essentially if
you were able to hack into GitHub
servers you would get access to the
entire world's code whether it's
financials social media games AI you
name it as GitHub likes to claim this is
worthy World built software and now it's
all controlled by Microsoft but how did
one company end up getting so much power
well it wasn't always like this guub
isn't something sort of Legacy tech
company that was founded in the 80s and
'90s GitHub was only founded 15 years
ago in 2008 and it started off as just a
regular old bootstrap startup funded by
four ambitious Engineers yet somehow
they've been able to convince the entire
world to jump on board but is this
actually safe and responsible I mean
we're essentially risking the entire
Tech world and really much of the world
economy on Microsoft security measures
well join me as we take a look at how
Microsoft came to control the entire
world's code and explore whether this is
actually in the world's best interest or
just Microsoft's best
[Music]
interest speaking of Microsoft's
domination with over a hundred billion
on cash and liquid Investments Microsoft
wipes the floor with other Fortune 500
companies when it comes to cash reserves
most of these liquid Investments are
actually in corporate and treasury bonds
as rates Rose over the past year
Microsoft leaned into bonds and locked
in high yields from the government and
other top corporations but it's not just
Microsoft who should get to capitalize
on today's high rate environment through
our upcoming Bond investing platform
Silo retail investors will get access to
these same institutional grade fixed
income opportunities as massive
corporations like Microsoft Silo's
mobile app allows you to build a
customized Bond portfolio tillor to your
risk tolerance and income needs so while
Microsoft profits from higher rates you
can too by investing in bonds through
Silo if that sounds interesting please
consider joining our wait list in the
description below to understand how
Microsoft came to dominate this world we
first have to understand how code used
to be stored and distributed before the
2000s because it was really bad I mean
just think about it when you have
thousands of coders who are working on
the same code base and making millions
of edits to add new features and fix
bugs you're naturally going to run into
a lot of issues Joe's bug revisions are
going to end up breaking Bob's new
feature John's new efficient algorithm
might have forgotten a critical Edge
case for Mary's Legacy functionality and
so on and so forth the bottom line is
that getting code from thousands of
Engineers to work together in unison is
a very difficult task in itself and for
the the longest time the solution for
this issue was simply Brute Force every
tech company would have their own
databases servers and revision control
systems and dozens of code Librarians
and Senior Engineers would be hired to
Simply maintain a healthy code base
these guys never wrote their own code or
algorithms or any of that instead their
full-time job was to Simply review each
and every change to ensure that none of
them would break any existing feature or
conflict with parallel changes honestly
this seems like a pretty tedious and
annoying job but it was also very much
critical and necessary that was until a
young man named lonus tals decided to
step in just kidding lonus didn't care
about this internal software engineering
issue he was looking to fry much bigger
fish and compete directly with Microsoft
if you haven't figured it out yet lonus
was the creator of Linux and that's
where he spent the first 15 years of his
professional life but eventually after
Linux grew to be much bigger than just
himself he would turned his attention to
one of one of the biggest frustrations
of software engineering Version Control
lonus was aware of this issue more than
anyone else as he was the head of the
biggest open- source project of all time
at least with companies you can be sure
that every engineer is killed and has
the company's best interest in mind at
least to some degree because well
they're getting paid with open source
software on the other hand literally
anyone can contribute so it was up to
people like lonus to ensure that only
the positive changes made their way onto
the re
this was always a pain in the butt for
lonus but he put up with it because he
was much more focused on the bigger
picture but on one fateful night in 2005
when working on the Linux kernel he
would reach his wits end with the crappy
Version Control he vowed right then and
there that he was going to solve this
issue once and for all and with that he
would go offline for 2 weeks create a
new revolutionary version control system
from scratch and call it get honestly
it's pretty funny to think that one of
the biggest shortfalls within the
software engineering industry could have
been solved or at least largely improved
with Just 2 weeks of focused work but
for whatever reason no one had decided
to take on this project for decades talk
about procrastination lus would of
course turn around and Implement git
into linux's repo which immediately gave
git a strong reputation within the open
source Community but there was still a
long way to go in terms of making get
mainstream
[Music]
you're probably wondering what in the
world did lonus do within just 2 weeks
that was so revolutionary well he
largely reduced the work of code
Librarians AKA The Gatekeepers before
get Engineers were often directly
working working on the central code base
and this is why having highly qualified
Gatekeepers was so important these
Gatekeepers were in charge of making
sure that only highquality code made its
way onto the repo but this also meant
that Engineers were spending a lot of
their time just waiting on Gatekeepers
instead of writing code ironically this
is still the case at most big tech
companies but for different reasons like
bureaucracy and varying priorities back
in the day the issue was mainly due to a
lack of good coding infrastructure G
however largely solved this instead of
having coders work directly on the
central repository G allowed coders to
work on a local version of the
repository this meant that coders could
test any change they wanted locally
without the oversight of Gatekeepers or
jeopardizing the central repo as such
coders were able to better troubleshoot
and validate their code before they ever
sent it to The Gatekeepers to verify and
merge with the central repo this was a
revolutionary development but git was by
no means perfect for starters there was
no front end to get everything was
handled through the terminal making it
difficult to visualize the history of
changes and modifications to a given
repo moreover sharing code between
Engineers still wasn't all that
streamlined or polished and this is
where four Engineers named Tom Preston
burner Chris vrad PJ Hyatt and Scott
checken would step in in 2008 these four
would get to work on putting a face get
making it easier than ever to share Fork
modify push and merge code for the first
time every developer on a project could
easily view the entire code history
identify who made what changes figure
out where things went wrong and fix
conflicts and production issues with
ease if a lot of those terms went over
your head they basically created an
insane code management platform based on
git and they called it logical awesome
LLC which is surprisingly similar to the
name of the channel unfortunately though
that name didn't stick and they would
end up calling it GitHub almost
immediately GitHub was a massive success
on its own it didn't need any venture
capital or funding or loans or any of
that in fact the founders were able to
manage all of the expenses of get by
themselves for the first 4 years after
all it's not that expensive to store and
distribute a bunch of text anyway one of
the first companies to embrace git was
none other than Google in 2008
this was during the peak of their
obsession with open- Source software
like Android and chromium they knew that
if they really wanted to appeal to the
open source Community they needed to use
the same tools which in this case was
git Google would eventually move away
from git to their own version
controlling tool called Piper but that
doesn't really matter because Google had
already put git and as a result GitHub
on the mainstream radar by 2010 GitHub
was hosting 1 million repos and by 2013
they were hosting 10 million repos most
tech companies were just happy to
finally have a modern code management
platform but some wanted a piece of the
pie this of course included VCS who
poured hundreds of millions into GitHub
but it also included
Microsoft
Microsoft didn't just go straight for
the acquisition instead they started off
as a regular old GitHub user and
supporter starting in 2012 they would
move all of their open source projects
Dev tools and most of their
documentation onto GitHub this did
wonders for GitHub it's one thing to
support a platform it's another to put
much of your own code on that platform
and at this point both Google and
Microsoft had taken the plunge let's
just say it was just a matter of time
until everyone else followed suit
Microsoft watched all of this play out
from the sidelines for several years
before finally making their move in
2018 the offer was $7.5 billion for the
entire company and frankly this was a
deal that the founders could not turn
down as it would make them billionaires
but with that being said the deal wasn't
really all that hostile either you see
Microsoft wasn't trying to take over and
impose their control over the company
all they really wanted was a star
investment and Cloud partner and that's
exactly how they've treated it and if
you don't believe me just take it from
GitHub CEO himself Microsoft has not
forgotten why we did the deal in the
first place and what the important
pillars of the deal are the first and
foremost principle is to put developers
first and that is what we do every day
that right there is a far cry from how
the founders of Instagram and WhatsApp
feel about Zuckerberg but that's a whole
another story anyway as you can see
things have worked out great for both
GitHub and Microsoft but what about
everyone else is it healthy and safe for
one company to have so much power well
if the question is healthy then the
answer is absolutely not it is not
healthy for one company to control the
code base of 90% of the Fortune 100
GitHub absolutely needs competition and
maybe even regular ERS but that'll
likely never happen because GitHub is a
background company that most people
don't even know or care about so as long
as they continue lurking in the
background they shouldn't have many
issues with Regulators but while the
system is definitely not healthy it is
surprisingly safe given github's
business they're naturally a target for
hackers a few years ago for example they
were subject to the largest DS attack
ever recorded but we don't really have
to to worry about this because giab's
customers know what they're doing here's
the thing 99% of the code in the world
doesn't matter not in the sense that
it's not important but in the sense that
it's not proprietary or special many of
the largest projects in the world like
Chrome and Android are already open-
source and even for the projects that
aren't open source the code base doesn't
really matter just because you have
Netflix or YouTube or reddit's code base
doesn't mean that that you'll even have
a chance at competing against them for
most tech companies their secret sauce
is their user base their marketing their
Partnerships their brand presence and so
on there's really nothing proprietary
about making API calls or storing data
or handling errors which is what the
vast majority of the world's code does
so companies aren't exactly worried
about their code bases getting leaked
though they would of course prefer to
not go down that road there's only a
very small number of projects and
companies that actually deal with
proprietary code where the code truly is
the hero and you can bet that these
projects are not stored on GitHub
they're stored on secret databases with
insane levels of security just like the
good old days but aside from these few
exceptions virtually everything is
stored on GitHub and that's how
Microsoft secretly controls every app in
the entire world it looks like Google
may also be trying to become a
background company check out this video
to learn more more but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one